[Music]  these are days for rejoicing  he's become  Oh  [Music]  after the defeat larysa uber Buuren left  Kattegat denarii we were hunting them  their escapes by betray because you are  back in England I agreed to give you  refuge here if you were willing to fight  with us against the armies of your  countrymen  the sons of King Ragnar lothbrok  on our side bad to fight for us  be very careful what you say about David  sir why will you kill me next I don't  belong here I want to take out to get  back from Iver you never overcome  catching it I'm going to do  King Alfred isn't trouble there are  those who want to overthrow him but pray  that none of you will betray me now  we'll fight against brother  may I ask why are you here now in person  because I miss your place  [Music]